i think it's been remarkable um
to have this level of panic uh you know
governor newsom
for example closed the zoos again now if
you're going to lock up
every poor child in los angeles or san
diego or san francisco
so that they're they're in a little
apartment uh they have no space
and then you're gonna close all the
public parks
uh what are these little kids supposed
to do and and it strikes me
that what you end up with is a public
health dictatorship
which is very singular in how it
measures things
i had a university president say to me
the other day
that he will lose more young people to
suicide
and drunk driving then he will lose to
covet
and he said they're reopening
he cannot understand why people have any
doubt at all about reopening
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report reminder everybody to subscribe
to our youtube channel and click that
pesky notification bell and joining me
today is the former speaker of the house
the author of over 40 books and the
chairman of gingrich 360 consulting
newt gingrich welcome to the reuben
report it's good to be with you
exciting i'm glad to have you you are
in rome at the moment what's what's
going on in rome these days
well as you know my wife calista is the
ambassador to the vatican
so that that's why we're here rome
actually has had a huge comeback
they uh got into big trouble back in
february because there are about a
hundred thousand
chinese workers in northern italy and
they were
allowing the flights to continue so they
were literally
flying in for wuhan bringing the disease
right here
and it got so out of control that their
hospital system was breaking down
and they were starting to triage people
and if you were over 80 they basically
said you're not getting
we're not going to take care of you
in fact kalista helped samaritan's purse
uh franklin graham's operation they flew
in an entire hospital
68 beds 60 doctors and nurses into the
worst hit part of northern italy
so the italian government closed
everything down we had
grocery stores uh pharmacies
gas stations that's it
if you were in the street uh you had to
have a good excuse
in writing or you could be fined uh 3
200 so for 10 weeks klister ran the
embassy
from our house virtually
and we did an amazing amount of zoom and
go to meeting and
what have you and uh for 10 weeks they
basically starved the virus
and gradually got it under control it's
now sufficiently under control
that they've reopened the restaurants
the museums
uh public parks stores
and you see people walking around now
problem for italy is
about 14 of their economy one out of
every seven dollars
is tourism and they don't have any
tourism yet
so places like the coliseum the last
year got 23
000 people a day you know they maybe
have 500 or a thousand a day
and so but that's a real economic crisis
for them but
but but in terms of the uh pandemic
they are in dramatically dramatically
better shape today
yeah so we're holding this interview for
a couple days so i don't want to ask you
anything about specifically what's
happening
today but but generally speaking the way
you see
the lockdown now in america and i'm here
in los angeles and and
literally just yesterday newsom put us
put us in another lockdown and
that these things seem to keep
continually happening we're watching
some spikes you know
it just seems that no one knows who to
trust at the moment
uh what's your take about how the states
have done it where
where trump fits into this and is there
something that you
would have been doing differently as
speaker of the house to to push your
guys
to push certain things uh differently
well i think i think
it's been remarkable um
to have this level of panic uh you know
governor newsom
for example closed the zoos again now if
you're going to lock up
every poor child in los angeles or san
diego or san francisco
so that they're they're in a little
apartment uh they have no space
and then you're going to close all the
public parks
uh what are these little kids supposed
to do and and it strikes me
that what you end up with is a public
health dictatorship
which is very singular in how it
measures things
uh i had a university president say to
me the other day
that he will lose more young people to
suicide and drunk driving
than he will lose to covet and
[Music]
he said they're reopening he cannot
understand
why people have any doubt at all about
reopening and so i would start from
there
the people you need to worry about half
of all the deaths
are people who are over 70 years of age
and in particular
the more you go up at 80 years it's more
dangerous at 90 it's even more dangerous
so you know that you want to really work
to protect
people who are over 70 but you don't
need to really work to protect people
who are 13.
uh and the idea that we're we've gone
from a country that used to know how to
open one house
school rooms and have seven classes in
one room
and people actually learned how to read
to an extraordinarily expensive
union-dominated bureaucracy that doesn't
want to teach
and you're gonna have this in los
angeles they've got it in new york i
mean
they've been in fairfax county virginia
one of the biggest and richest
school districts in the country why
would we pay people to not teach
uh why would we have all these big fancy
buildings nobody can go to
and i think it really raises very
profound questions
about the whole system yeah well that
actually is perfect segue because i was
going to say as someone that's a true
lover
of american history and has written
about it and you talk about american
history all the time
are you sort of shocked the way the
average american person
just sort of takes orders and doesn't
necessarily
ask why are these things happening you
know at one time it was flat in the
curve
we don't hear the phrase flatten the
curve anymore we haven't heard it
excuse me for about six weeks now it
seems to be something else or they just
give us an order
and they don't really tell you why well
i mean
part of it has been i think the
evolution from a
news media to a propaganda media so that
you have these waves of coverage
i compared it to watching the
flagellante in the middle ages this was
a group
that would go from city to city beating
themselves and so you have all these
people out here
uh who are they panic um
you know the truth is if you look at the
death rate there's no reason to panic
uh this is not uh the bubonic plague
it's it's not ebola uh most people who
get
first of all an amazing percentage who
get the
um the by the chinese virus which is
what it is
most of them don't even know they have
it
when you told somebody tested positive
who was quote asymptomatic
that means whatever symptoms they had
were so mild
that it didn't affect them so you have
to then stop and say wait a second
why are we panicking over people
you know the numbers go up but the
numbers go up with people under 35
who are totally healthy uh and i think
the i have been truly appalled my my
younger daughter jack bushman
as a certified financial analyst and
used to run a very large budget
billion dollar plus budget and she said
to me the other night and just share
disgust she said i have never seen
statistics
put together so badly that it is
impossible to know what's actually
happened
and she's just literally fed up and
distinct whether it's because the
government statistics are so incompetent
or whether it's because the news media
is deliberately you know they're going
they're going from worst case to worst
case to worst case
so they don't tell you that for example
uh georgia has about ten percent of the
fatality rate of new york
they praise cuomo who is the worst
governor of the country
but has been praised so much by the news
media that he now has a very high
popularity rating in new york
while he killed people in at least six
to eight thousand senior citizens
died because of governor cuomo and
decisions he made
but that somehow gets brushed over
because you know he's liberal
and therefore it's okay yeah so let's
sit with that for a little bit because
you know i think a lot of people think
that trump was sort of the first guy
the first mainstream politician in a
modern sense to really go after the
media but i remember your campaign in
2012 really well
and you were capturing that populist
sentiment and during the debate
you know you won a couple debates in a
row and you had the crowds cheering and
screaming to the point that
the networks were asking crowds not to
make sounds during the debates which
in many ways sort of deflated your
candidacy because you were using their
their energy um that's sort of relevant
to what you just said there about cuomo
because democrats seem to be able to get
away
with virtually anything and then blaming
it on the other guy because they know
the media runs cover for them
you guys don't get that luxury well
look i mean you could tell that that
romney was the media choice because they
rigged towards the end
they just rigged the i mean it was
amazing when i got up on stage they said
nobody gets to applaud nobody has to do
this nobody has to do that
uh and i looked at it and and uh it was
truly anti-popular i mean it was there
was as elitist
as you could possibly be and i frankly
watch
when you say when you say they when you
say they do you mean that's coming from
the networks or
or coming from the rnc no no coming from
the network
the network the networks had decided
that romney was the low-risk moderate
candidate
uh that that they could survive with uh
and that i really was their their mortal
enemy which is true
i mean if if you're gonna destroy the
new york times
and turn it into a propaganda machine
then as somebody who grew up when there
really was a news media
i am deeply opposed to you and i don't
mind going head-to-head with all these
people
um i really admired trump in that sense
because i thought in 15 and 16
he did the best job i've ever seen
better than reagan
better than me at taking on the media
and winning i mean
it's just a straight knock down drag out
fight and uh
and then he's had to do that because
they are a propaganda system they're not
a news media
they are about 93 against trump
they lie about him when he gave this
terrific speech at mount rushmore which
was a great
redefinition of american exceptionalism
and why we matter
when they couldn't find anything in the
speech they just lied about it was the
most amazing thing in fact
michael barone is a very common sense
practical guy
wrote a column saying this is the most
dishonest news media of his lifetime
and that he thinks it will come back to
haunt the news media
for having betrayed the trust of the
american people
are you worried that as those
institutions crumble
we're going to lose some sort of
national cohesion
this has come up with almost all of my
guests because everyone at this point
basically agrees that the media is
crumbling they've done this to
themselves they
they seem to double down every time
instead of you know having a moment of
self-reflection
but are you worried that if the new york
times fails if
cnn if just the media and then the rest
of the institutions because that then
spreads to academia and everywhere else
that if these institutions all crumble
you know you know we almost have no
way of having a national ethos at some
level
well i look i think there are other
institutions that emerge
i think there's an amazing amount of
information now
on the internet through facebook and
youtube and a bride
twitter although twitter's very has a
lot of hostility in it
but uh you know and you have places like
c-span which really are
uh remarkably neutral in fact i have
watched several trump speeches on c-span
you also have an ability to stream
things the president uh streams a lot of
his speeches and
puts denial watch his speeches uh his
stream from the white house
we also frankly during the lockdown got
into watching both
saint peter's and the basilica in
washington
because they were streaming mass so
you're entering a world
of dramatically more media not lesbian
just as your show
is another example of more media not
less media but
we're going to have a really deep split
because
we're in the middle of a cultural civil
war and there's just no question in my
mind
that this is the most divided we've been
since the
election of lincoln in 1860 and his
re-election in 1864
and that part of the reason i wrote uh
trump
on the american future is that i really
do believe
that what happens this fall may do more
to shape
america's future than any election since
1864
and i say that because i think that the
biden
pelosi schumer team will be so
radical that we would not recognize the
country within two or three years
they would have moved us so far to the
left do you think that it's the biden
schumer pelosi team that are actually
the true radicals or do you think it's
the
it's the bernie crew and the aoc crew
beneath them that's sort of just
shifting them that way or do you really
feel like they
are actually that radical it's a little
hard to tell these days if they're a
little more old school
and you know the tail is wagging the dog
basically yeah
i mean a little bit like saying when you
get when you get run over by the truck
you know do you think the driver was
deliberately trying to run or that
general
policy he got run over uh
when schumer the other day came out for
the 10 cut in defense spending
which sanders is offering as an
amendment uh and when pelosi brought up
a bill which 207 democrats voted for
that gives a twelve hundred dollar bonus
to every illegal immigrant don't you
think about this
207 democrats voted to give a twelve
hundred dollar bonus check
to every illegal immigrant i mean you
have to wonder
these people just crazy um
biden has said that he would uh
sign the pelosi bill which is a three
trillion dollar
very radical bill he certainly didn't
see biden
uh criticizing uh the looters and the
violence in fact
13 of biden's staff actually helped bail
out
looters and violent people in
minneapolis so i just
you know i think there's a pattern in
trump and the american future
i put in a chapter
that the democrats love criminals and
hate police
and i think if you look at seattle
minneapolis chicago
new york i think that that's the
objective evidence
so as we watch these progressive cities
crumble
the several you just named there and we
can we can go on the list all the cities
with the worst violence and the worst
gun violence and the highest rates of
murders
they're all i think 19 out of 20 or
something like that are progressive-run
cities
do you sense that sort of what those
mayors
and and the governors to another extent
want is they
want the chaos so that trump has to
bring in
troops or the national guard like
they're almost laying out a trap so that
he looks like
the authoritarian that they wish him to
be
no i i think um i mean i don't think
they mind that happening but i don't
think that's what they're doing
i think that the left really has this
fantasy image of how the world works and
they really think that if only there
were no policemen
it's sort of like they the the
democratic mayor of seattle
who said that we were gonna have a
summer of love when they created the
autonomous district now
poor people got killed and she gave up
on that although ironically
she didn't really give up on it until
the demonstrators came to her home one
night
suddenly when they were surrounding her
house yeah that's
she said something that's real but i
think um part of it is
that their their radical left-wing
ideology
doesn't allow them to deal with reality
so you end up with uh
let's cut the budget of the new york
police department a billion dollars
when there were i think um 13 people
shot yeah on monday
chicago has few too few policemen not
too many
and they have a dozen or more people
shot every weekend
um you know after all the problems in
minneapolis
they're now moving to uh dissolve the
police department
and and and in my mind
you know if you if you stop and say walk
me through this
there's an armed gunman it's two o'clock
in the morning
you're going to send social workers to
chat with the government
i just need to understand how their
worldview works
but but i've i went back recently uh
rachel peterson is our chief researcher
and she pulled up 35 pages of material
on the actual black lives matter
organization and when he's founded by
three marxists
and when you read about their real
beliefs you begin to understand
they live in an alternative worldview
they live in a world where the police
are really
very dangerous and they don't quite have
an explanation for all the other people
get killed because you're
if you're an african-american male
you're 300 times more likely
to be shot by a criminal than by the
police uh but that doesn't matter
because
you know the police are an extension of
the authoritarian power of the white
male dominated culture which is what
they're really mad about
whereas if you just happen to get killed
by your neighbor that doesn't really
count so
you know an eight-year-old girl gets
killed in atlanta well that's
unfortunate
but it's not something that black lives
matter is going to do anything about but
she wasn't killed by a policeman
seven-year-old gets killed in chicago
well that's really unfortunate
but it's not really a political event
because she wasn't killed by a policeman
so you really have this very weird
period underway where the left has
no model to explain how they would
achieve
peace just as by the way they have no
model to explain how they would educate
children you look at
baltimore which has the fourth most
expensive school system in the country
and has entire buildings in which not a
single child can pass the exam not one
to which biden's comments this week were
maybe we need to quit um testing
because after all it probably makes them
feel bad that they didn't pass the test
right and then and then at the same time
they don't seem to want school choice or
charter schools to allow
for more ability to get a plurality of
education out there and help these kids
it's it's
quite bizarre to say it can't be because
um the democratic party is a wholly
owned subsidiary of the teachers union
i think at one of the recent conventions
half the delegates
who are from the teachers union and the
teachers union is essentially a machine
to get paid
there's nothing to do with teaching you
can tell that by the fact they don't
want to go back to school
and it has nothing to do with effective
teaching you can tell that because look
at baltimore when
you think of baltimore as a machine for
the payment of union members
it is a remarkable system if you think
of it as an educational system
it is an unbelievably terrible system
and the democrats cannot they they have
no capacity
to take on the teachers union anywhere
in the country
so they basically say yeah you might be
destroying the children
but at least the union will help you get
reelected
so with all this in mind what do you
think the republicans
if anything could be doing better as
we're watching monuments being taken
down
and we're watching the mob just run
across cities
um you know i see the republicans are
sort of talking a tough game and trump's
talking a tough game but
but are they not doing something that
they actually should be doing because
this stuff
isn't stopping well i think there's a
couple things they should be doing first
of all
in the long run they should the
republican national committee
to go into every major city and create a
jobs prosperity and safety
chapter and start to organize everybody
in the city
to win municipal elections and state
legislative elections
who are secretary of having people
killed and now then they ought to plant
a flag in every one of these cities
and say we're going to reach out to
everybody who's sick and tired of having
no jobs
no schools that work and have and having
your relatives shot
and if that fits you let's sit down and
talk about you know how you can be a
candidate not not
we're not going to ask you to vote for
some traditional republican but we're
going to try to help you take back
your city second i think
that the president has to look at the
example
that bobby kennedy set in the early 80s
and the early 60s
when young volunteers were being killed
in mississippi
during the civil rights movement and it
was clear
that the local sheriff who may have been
doing the killing and the state police
were not going to defend these people
and what they did is they said look
these are american citizens
and if you're not going to defend them
we are and they sent in the fbi
and i think in a number of these places
the the young woman in indianapolis the
mother of a three-year-old
who was apparently shot over the weekend
for saying all lives matter um
you know there's a perfect example where
she lost
all of her civil rights because she's
dead uh
i think they ought to say you know we we
are now going to create
strike forces that are going to be
prepared to go into the south side of
chicago
prepared to go into new york any place
which has
is clearly spinning out of control if
you
if you won't protect your own citizens
we will
because they're american citizens and
and i think we have to be prepared to to
be much more aggressive
and much tougher uh about taking this on
then lastly we ought to create much
bigger uh
and and more attractive opportunity
zones uh with the
benefits so great and with with
education opportunities so great
uh though we can actually begin to
create jobs in the inner city
everywhere in the country are you
worried with all that in mind that this
this mix between covid and riots and
protests
is gonna do sort of irreparable damage
to small business across the board no
matter what at this point because
if you weren't taken out by kovid and
now again with the lockdowns if you
somehow survived i have a friend who
called me yesterday who's a
uh who's she's a masseuse she usually
goes to people's homes
she can't go to people's homes anymore
she got a little shop over the last
couple weeks just a little one room
place
now they closed her down and she's
thinking of leaving california now and
she's not even sure what she's gonna do
for a living anymore
that the average person you know the
corporations can basically deal with
these big blows but the average person
just can't you know figure out a way to
live if every month
something crazy is going to happen look
i mean even big corporations brooks
brothers for example
which is a you know almost 200 year old
company may have actually be 200 years
old
has filed for bankruptcy right uh united
airlines i mean
even really big places can get in
trouble but
the points you make is important at a
couple of levels i i work very closely
uh with alfredo ortiz and the job
creators network and
they do terrific work helping small
businesses
and we have been much more proactive
than the europeans
at trying to help small businesses but i
think one of the things you're going to
see
is people are going to leave california
people are going to leave big cities
i mean i would not be at all surprised
to see new york lose virtually everybody
who has any resources
just because the taxes are too high the
streets are going to be unsafe
again you know people don't want to be
in a place that's out of control
if you look at seattle the most radical
member of the city council
talks about getting visas now
jesus is the richest guy in the world so
he's an obvious target if you're a
socialist
but if you want to drive amazon
out of king county and seattle
you want to look at the yeah this is
what aoc did when she blocked them
from going into her congressional
district and cost that
part of new york city 25 000 jobs
and i don't think this would not
surprise me one morning
bezos announced that amazon was moving
everything
out of seattle and the cost of the tax
both directly from amazon and indirectly
from all the workers who would then
leave
would be just staggering i mean it would
turn would turn seattle into detroit
all right so let's let's back up a
little bit because i know we can we can
sort of focus on this for
for the entire hour but i think your
career sort of well we could we could do
several hours on this easily
but i think your career and some of the
things that you have done
might help sort of light a way that we
can get out of some of this stuff so
when when you were speaker of the house
can you just talk a little bit about
how democrats and republicans could or
could not
work together and what you think has
happened that has led us to just
i mean there's virtually none of it now
um how you were able to
to make some of those fights and and
build some of those bridges or
have some of those bridges burned well i
would point out that in fact
when the crisis really hit this spring
uh the the house and senate did manage
to give
steve mnuchin to the treasury some real
credit
but the house and senate actually worked
together and produced
trillions of dollars in spending i mean
that was they did it pretty fast
they did it pretty cleanly there also
has been a steady stream of small bills
that people can get together and agree
on lamar alexander
the senator from tennessee is probably
the best example that he's a genius
at figuring out what they can do rather
than what what they can't do
um but the key
to what we did was very explicit and
people
want to know about it can read a very
simple small book
by tom evans called the education of
ronald reagan
reagan had after his movie career and
his tv career
he ended up spending eight years working
for general electric
and uh it was really interesting story
because
he went around the country as a
spokesperson he talked gave about 375
speeches to factories
so he had a lot of practice talking to
blue collar workers taking
questions being a celebrity
which was great preparation for running
for governor and
in the process reagan was in a period
where he wouldn't fly an airplane he did
a
really bouncy flight in i think late 45
so he did not fly an airplane again
until 1965.
and so he went everywhere by train and
the guy he worked for was a very
conservative
uh intellectual the head of human human
relations and
union relations at general electric and
so this guy would give reagan
conservative economic votes
so here you have reagan driving you know
riding across the country on a train
reading conservative economics preparing
his speeches
well reagan came up with a model which
you really got from from this particular
guy
which reagan summarized in
everyday language by saying my job is to
shine the light on the american people
so they will turn up the heat on
congress
but what that meant was you had to have
a program like three-year tax cuts
that was popular enough that the
american people would say to their
congressman
i really want you to pass this and i've
been arguing for example
that the administration should come out
for a one-year holiday
in the uh payroll tax
because it would be enormously helpful
you got me
and the self-employed and it would be
more money in the pocket of every single
working american
and that would be the kind of popular
proposal that you could then build heat
on pelosi
not because you're in the room
negotiating with her but because you're
talking to the whole country
and the country is telling her members i
really want you to vote for this
so i really think that when
for example when we finally passed
uh welfare reform uh there was a tie
there was a poll
92 percent of the country thought we
should reform welfare
including 88 of people who were on
welfare
well at that point half the democrats
voted with us
from 101 to 101 among democrats because
you went back home and people said
you are going to vote for this aren't
you and i think that's that's
the real keys is pick fights that are
so popular that the american people will
pressure the congress into being for it
do you think that's a little more
complex now
because of the cult of personality
around trump
or just the the way the media talks
about trump or what
people think about trump or what they
say about half the country
that getting anything that he wants done
is is going to inherently be more
difficult
well i think to some extent it's more
difficult but on the other hand
he did they did a great job of focusing
on their tax cuts
they got him through they got him
approved those are certainly not things
that the democrats wanted to do
he did a very he's done a very good job
building up the defense system
and communicating why that's really
important
mcconnell's done an amazing job getting
in the senate getting uh
conservative judges approved the most
successful
first term i think in american history
so
it's it's a mixed bag i think i think
trump finds it
i think at times his personal
aggressiveness gets in the way of his
effectiveness
and i think that sometimes it's a little
bit like
the green bay packers at their peak had
a great running back named jimmy taylor
who'd come to lsu
and uh taylor was an enormously strong
guy
and someone made the comment one time
that about the fifth year
in the nfl taylor finally realized it
was okay to go slow enough
that the pulling guard could get ahead
of you
and could actually block for you you
didn't have to go knock everybody down
by yourself
i think trump has never quite learned
the jimmy taylor lesson that
you know there are lots of people who
want to help the president
when he picks the right big issues uh he
could have a huge army of people
talking about it helping the congress
getting it through
but that requires a more uh slower paced
and more leadership
style rather than i can do it all myself
yeah are you shocked in in all your
years doing this and in government and
now in consulting
how often it seems that the average
person
sort of doesn't know what's in their
best interest like something like you
just mentioned about the payroll tax cut
or just generally tax cuts
i'm always for tax cuts you cut taxes on
business now people are going to have
more money you cut
personal income tax people are going to
have more money i would much rather
people decide what to do with their
money than
than the government but yet a huge
percentage of people seem to think oh we
just have to keep throwing money at
things
no matter what the evidence says is that
like just one of the ongoing
battles that you have to have sort of
intellectually part of it
that's part of remember some of it's
self-serving uh i mean if you're a uh
racial studies graduate from harvard
and you have this great new idea for a
program where the federal government
will hire 600
racial studies experts to brainwash the
rest of us
i mean you just figured out a whole new
career for yourself
uh if you're the teachers union you know
you'd love to have more money i mean
that
that's i understand the same thing's
true for the police union for that i
mean
so there's a certain amount of uh
self-aggrandizement there's a certain
look there's a fair amount of
not thinking about this stuff for the
practical reason that in a free society
most of the time
you shouldn't have to uh you know so
and our education system right now is so
totally screwed up
as reagan once said it's not what they
don't know that's scary it's what they
know that isn't true
let me say one more thing about this
though yeah one of the great lessons i
learned
was from a book by tony schwartz
called the election game and how to win
i'm sorry uh
and wouldn't get the name of the title
right now she's gonna give you the wrong
title
anyway tony schwartz was a great radio
consultant he then went into politics he
did
he did lots of radio ads and he was very
good
at understanding the idea that
it's called the responsive cord his
theory was
he wanted to talk about something that
was already in your brain
so all he's doing is triggering the
response he's not
filling it up but he had a very good
sound rule he said
never underestimate the intelligence the
american people
nor overestimate the amount of
information they have
very often they won't have the right
information and so they'll look like
they don't know
but if you will make sure to get them
the right information
they will then figure out the right
solution and i found in my career that
was almost always true
and i'm trying to convince the frankly
the republicans this year
that if they'll calmly and methodically
run a very fact-based campaign
uh that they'll be shocked at how well
they'll do for example um
in a pew poll recently three out of four
americans oppose
uh defunding the police
now and frankly of the 25 percent who
are in favor of defunding
about half of them don't want to do very
much so the really hardcore left-wing
radicals
are about 12 or 13 percent of the
country
well i mean republicans ought to be able
to win that fight
you ought to be able to beat a whole
bunch of house democrats who are running
around
and senate democrats and frankly since
biden
you know biden is in this wishy-washy
well i'm i'm really not for totally
defunding but i'm for a little bit
defending
um that ain't going to cut it not no not
when you say to him
so two weekends ago there were 152
americans shot
in new york and chicago combined 152.
so mr biden what's your answer to 152
americans being shot
and the truth is he has no answer
are you shocked then that they ended up
going with biden i mean
he's been around forever you know i know
you're no fan of hillary clinton but at
least there was
some base that was that was seriously
excited about her that that's undeniable
but i don't see anyone that's excited
about biden and if anything
you know he's obviously having some
cognitive problems and the media seems
to be running cover for it
and it's it's i don't mean that to be
glib or funny or anything i mean it's
sad in a way but that there's no
excitement
behind this thing do you think they're
going to regret
that this was the choice well you you
actually got me to think something i
hadn't thought about
there's a fascinating almost
180 degree opposite between the
republican
selection process of 16 and the and the
biden
process in 16 trump kept knocking people
out
i mean you know he started i think with
jeb bush and he just methodically went
after people
and just kept knocking him out biden
passively allowed everybody else to
shoot themselves
so they would you know i mean everybody
got a shot at it everybody had their
moment the sun
and then they failed and so people say
well not him or we're not her
and biden ultimately was i think relying
on two things he had
he started the dance with very high name
id
i think only sanders had equal new id
and second
he had spent eight years
standing next to barack obama and in
south carolina
if you can carry the black vote in the
democratic primary
you will win the primary and his
entire reason for being
was to set up
getting to south carolina so as long as
he didn't knock himself out
none of the rest of them had the ability
to knock him out
and he just said to be standing there
and then they did something very smart
which is i'm sure they work
behind the scenes and they got three or
four people to decide to endorse him as
soon as he won south carolina
she suddenly had this momentum of
excitement that carries into super
tuesday
uh and think about it by super tuesday
you're down to sanders
who however far to the left biden is
sanders will always be 20 feet further
to the left yeah if biden moves left
sanders move even further so in the end
sanders base was probably 40 or 45
of the party do you think we have to do
anything
i know you're not a democrat obviously
but on either side as far as the primary
process
you know they run primaries very
differently we saw the disaster in iowa
do you think we just have to continue
with this or is there anything in modern
times that we should do to change some
of this
i mean look i think the democratic
party's incompetence in iowa
uh is just part of their how badly
structured their party is
um i mean we had a very similar problem
by the way
in 12 because the truth was that rick
santorum won iowa
the party chairman at that time
called it for romney it took six or
seven days for it to be obvious that it
was santorum
so santorum lost all of the advantage he
would have had going into new hampshire
romney had a false advantage
and the state chairman i think was in
fact
economically leaning towards romney in
ways that were totally inappropriate he
had to resign
so we've had some of our own problems
with this stuff but i think the primary
process at one level is really a good
thing
because it does allow you uh
to go out and meet people now
the challenge is going to be as we move
into this age of
social media on a giant scale
whether or not it makes sense just
because
you know we've we've been in the middle
of a full-blown presidential race i
would guess for
a year now and and
in that sense it's not clear to me how
things will evolve in the future
but we also had absolute proof for
example uh that um
the the bloomberg spent a couple hundred
million dollars and got nowhere
uh because in the end when you watched
him on a debate stage you just knew
this guy was impossible so you know it's
it's
it's business how it shakes things out
yeah when you were watching bloomberg in
those two or three debates i mean as a
guy that was a great
an r you are a great debater i mean you
knew how to use the crowd you knew how
to use humor
you knew how to you know directly go
after opponent
it must have been sort of painful for
you to watch some of these guys that
just have no idea how to debate is it
painful or is it shocking or
do you feel good about yourself no it's
fun
i mean look as long as it's the other
side i'm happy for them to be
incompetent
uh you know i don't i don't feel like i
have an obligation to
this is not like a an ice skating
competition where i'm going to give them
a nine or an eight
uh you know so i i watch some of it
i don't actually watch probably as much
as i should
just because i think it's boring and i
can only take so much of it
but i'll tell you in 16
and late 15 i guess i really started the
summer of 15.
um i remember the first fox debate
which was the first debate of the 2016
cycle
and that's the one where megyn kelly and
donald trump
know this knockdown dragon fight and i
was sitting at home with calista we were
watching the debate
but i was also watching all the various
online
you know like time magazine and vogue
and a whole bunch of
all sorts of places you could go to
register who you thought won
and about an hour and a half after the
debate
and i watched once and what i thought
was one of the
uh most um
inaccurate focus groups he'd ever done
i like frank a lot of old friends but
what happened was
you'd have to be very careful in things
like focus groups
because a group mindset will set in and
if people conclude
he must have done bad because she said
he did bad so he must have done bad
i don't want to be the guy said he did
good so what happened what was happening
was
all of the experts were trashing trump
lunz's focus group was trashing trump
but in a field of 16 candidates
he was getting 60 to 70 percent of the
vote in these online surveys
and i remember turning to kalista about
midnight i yes and saying
as a historian there's an anomaly
building here
the gap between lead opinion and the
average american is getting so big
that we should watch this carefully
because something's going on we don't
understand
and that's really how i approach that i
use a model of listen learn help and
lead
and i really find that the world's so
big and changes so constantly
that i have to listen and learn all the
time and i so i approach every
activity with a i wonder what i'll learn
from it
huh you'll probably find this
interesting actually when i had david
horowitz on who i'm sure you either know
or certainly know his work i i asked him
uh when did he realize that trump was
the real deal and he said it was the
exact moment
that trump got into the fight with megyn
kelly because he realized nobody else
would have ever done it
and that was it and and he fully went
there
uh let's talk a little bit about history
though because we seem to be in this
time where we're
uh erasing history is there
is there something that for my younger
audience some piece of american history
that maybe
isn't the most known piece that you
think people should know more about that
might help us
get a lens on what's going on now
sure i wrote three novels
about the revolutionary war and four
novels
about um the uh
or no the four novels about the civil
war
and uh
i think the most amazing moment in the
history of america
is christmas night 1776.
uh we did it in a book called the the
times the try men's souls which is the
quote from haynes uh
the crisis washington's army
has shrunk from 30 000 in september
to about 2500. and they have a council
of war and washington says
most of these guys the
enlistments end in first or second week
of january
and if we don't do something the army
will disappear
and he says now all of us in this room
have no risk because
if the army disappears we're all going
to be hung
so we can take really big risks because
our life's already forfeit
yeah and so he came up with a plan which
was complex too complicated
to cross a icy river in the middle of a
snowstorm
at night in three different places he
would lead the main elements
he had as a sign of great leadership
he had taken thomas paine who'd written
an amazing
uh pamphlet called common sense which
explained the revolutionary war
to everyday people and payne had
enlisted as a rifleman
and on the way through new jersey
washington took him aside and said
go to philadelphia and write a pamphlet
that explains
why what do we do we all thought this
was going to be easy
well it's going to be hard and we need
somebody to explain it to us
so payne literally had gone to
philadelphia and wrote the crisis
washington had his officers
read from the opening chapter of the
crisis
as the men got in the boats to cross the
river
wow when they finished crossing the
river they marched eight miles in a
snowstorm
at night one third of them did not have
boots and had wrapped their feet in
burlap bags
the next morning they surprised the the
professional german soldiers
captured 800 of them and ran like crazy
and crossed the river before the british
army could get there
the news of that victory brought
15 000 volunteers in two weeks
it's the decisive moment of the war now
i cite that for younger people because
all of these totally uninformed idiots
who downplay washington have no idea
what real life is
you know real life is not being coddled
in some university
surrounded by people who make sure you
have a safe space
real life is facing gigantic challenges
and finding the character and the
courage and the endurance
to build something to do something real
and this country stands on george
washington's shoulders
uh we would not have won the
revolutionary war without him we might
not have gotten the constitutional
convention without him
and he served as our first president for
eight years and established precedents
which to this day
uh are the mark of freedom and uh
i would just say it is tragic that we've
allowed three generations of
brainwashing
to destroy the understanding of the real
america
for millions of young americans
well it's an inspirational story but i
can't end with that so we're gonna have
to end
i can't end with that sort of i can't
end with that sort of ending of what
we've done to the three generations so
let's
let's clean it up let's clean it up in a
way i know you you will do well
which is for all of the people that are
worried right now they're worried about
their jobs they're worried about the
political polarization they're worried
about lockdowns and covet and everything
else
can you can you paint a bit of a future
that they can be hopeful for that can
get us
out of this i mean you see it beginning
to happen all around you
we're going to have an explosive
increase in the ability to educate
people
the recent the recent announcements by
amazon and google and others
and apple we're going to have remarkable
capacity
to people go and get great jobs we're
going to become once again the number
one industrial country in the world
we're going to remain the number one
producer of energy in the world uh we're
going to get to the moon
by 2024 and we're going to be on mars by
2033.
our children and grandchildren are going
to be literally mining asteroids and
running commercial hotels in space
we will have breakthroughs in medicine
we're about to have i think a cure for
sickle cell anemia
which will be of enormous importance to
the black community
when when we get aging declared as a
disease
so that the nih can actually focus
on lengthening lives i think the odds
are very good
that we are going to have uh something
like
um the average person living living
very healthily to 110 or 120
not not getting ancient but literally
being active and having a full life
so i think the long run trajectory of
the human race is pretty good do we have
problems sure
we've always had problems it's the
nature of life uh but i think that
young people have every reason to
believe that by the end of their lives
the world will be
more interesting more exciting more
prosperous and the opportunity for
adventure will be even greater
i knew you could do it mr speaker how do
we
where should i send people you've got
like a thousand websites and a million
projects where can we where can we send
people to you're not retiring anytime
soon
my newsletters my podcasts my books all
those things are gingrich 360.
they can also of course get the books at
either barnes and noble amazon or
any major bookstore uh and and i'm very
proud of
trump and the american future because i
think it captures some of this
extraordinary gap between a bad future
with the left and an amazingly good
future
if we win this election this fall if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell